Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The Italian people have already suffered terribly. Their manhood has been cast away in Africa and Russia. Their soldiers have been deserted in the field. We have seen that ourselves. Their wealth has been squandered. Their empire has been lost, irretrievably lost.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。意大利人民已经遭受了极其惨重的苦难。他们的男儿在非洲和俄罗斯丧生。他们的士兵在战场上被抛弃。我们亲眼目睹了这一切。他们的财富被挥霍一空。他们的帝国已经丧失，无可挽回地丧失了。
Now their own beautiful homeland must become a battlefield for German rearguards. Even more suffering lies ahead. They are to be pillaged and terrorized in Hitler's fury and revenge. Nevertheless, as the armies of the British Empire and the United States march forward in Italy, as we shall march, the Italian people will be rescued from their state of servitude and degradation, and will be enabled in due course to regain their rightful place among the free democracies of the modern world. So that was an archive recording of Winston Churchill. Oh, that's who it was.
现在，他们美丽的家园必须成为德国后卫部队的战场。更多的苦难还在前方。他们将在希特勒的愤怒和报复中遭受掠夺和恐吓。然而，随着大英帝国和美国的军队在意大利挺进，正如我们将要进军的那样，意大利人民将从奴役和堕落的状态中被解救出来，并将在适当的时候恢复他们在现代世界自由民主国家中应有的地位。以上是温斯顿·丘吉尔的一段档案录音。哦，原来是他。
It was one of the very first recordings ever made of Parliament, Tom. So Parliament had just come back after the summer recess. That was the 21st of September, 1943. And Churchill was reporting to the House of Commons on the 21st of September, 1943. And Churchill was reporting to the House of Commons on the state of the war in Italy, where the Allies had just made this extraordinary decision to land in Italy and to fight their way up, Tom, through what some people say Churchill called the soft underbelly of the Axis. Whether he did actually say that, I imagine we will discover today. I imagine we we will and it was 80 years ago this year was it not yeah it was not today as
汤姆，这是议会最早的录音之一。当时议会刚刚结束暑期休会。那是1943年9月21日。丘吉尔当时正在向英国下议院报告意大利战场的局势，盟军刚刚做出了一个非凡的决定，即登陆意大利并一路打上去，汤姆，穿过一些人所说的丘吉尔口中的“轴心国的软腹部”。至于他是否真的说过这句话，我想我们今天会揭晓。我想我们会知道的，而且今年正好是80年前，不是吗？是的，不是今天，正如
you said when we originally recorded this segment no and we've recorded that because i goofed and thank you for drawing attention to it for everyone to sneer and laugh at me i'm kind that way kind to the listeners i think that it's just like to like to share and we're not perfect. So the soft underbelly, of course, it proves not to be a soft underbelly, does it? Because, well, actually, let me read a passage from a recently published book by an absolutely top historian of the Second World War that's just come out and is available in all good bookshops ready for Christmas. And this top historian writes, the invasion of Italy conceived in August in the heat and sun of aranean summer and based on dubious intelligence that hitler planned to swiftly retreat north of rome had been launched on the understanding that its objectives would be
你所说的，当我们最初录制这一段时，不，我们录制了那个，因为我搞砸了，感谢你引起大家的注意，让大家嘲笑我，我就是这样的人，对听众很友善，我想这就像是喜欢分享，而且我们并不完美。所以，“软腹部”当然被证明并不是什么软腹部，对吧？因为，好吧，让我读一段最近出版的一本书中的段落，作者是一位绝对顶尖的二战历史学家，这本书刚刚出版，在所有好的书店都能买到，准备迎接圣诞节。这位顶尖历史学家写道，这次意大利入侵构想于八月的地中海夏日，基于希特勒计划迅速撤退到罗马以北的可疑情报，其发起的前提是目标能够
quickly achieved that the capital would be in allied hands in a trice and that it would be a limited operation but dominic it proves to be none of those things, does it? Because it's an absolutely brutal slog. There's not enough troops, not enough kit. It's all being husbanded for D-Day. And the result really is quite a forgotten campaign. A forgotten quagmire, Tom. Well, I would say a forgotten savage storm, Dominic, which is the title of the book that I was mentioning, The Savage Storm, The Battle for Italy, 1943, by the top historian of the Second World War, who is my brother, James, James Holland, who is also, of course, presenter on the top Second World War podcast, We Have Ways of Making You Talk. And he's joining us all the way from Cornwall. Hello, bro.
迅速实现，首都将很快落入盟军手中，而且这将是一次有限的行动，但多米尼克，事实证明根本不是这样，对吧？因为这是一场极其残酷的苦难。没有足够的部队，没有足够的装备。一切都被留给了诺曼底登陆。结果确实是一场被遗忘的战役。一场被遗忘的泥潭，汤姆。嗯，我会说是一场被遗忘的残酷风暴，多米尼克，这就是我提到的那本书的标题，《残酷的风暴：1943年意大利之战》，作者是二战的顶尖历史学家，也就是我的兄弟詹姆斯，詹姆斯·霍兰德，他当然也是二战顶级播客《我们有办法让你开口》（We Have Ways of Making You Talk）的主持人。他正从康沃尔郡加入我们。你好，兄弟。
What's up, bro? Thanks for the intro. Great impersonation of Churchill, I thought there. Thank you. Very fine. You can come on again. It's a shame bro? Thanks for the intro. Great impersonation of Churchill, I thought there. Thank you. Very fine. You can come on again. It's a shame you never had to say Nazi. Yeah. I always feel that should be included in any wartime impersonation. That's the giveaway, isn't it?
怎么了，兄弟？谢谢你的介绍。我觉得你刚才模仿丘吉尔模仿得很好。谢谢。非常棒。你可以再来一次。可惜你从来不用说“纳粹”（Nazi）。是的。我一直觉得任何战时模仿都应该包括这个。那是标志性的特征，不是吗？
That he always says Nazi rather than Nazi. Nazi. Yeah. But can I just refocus on the savage storm? Because also, bro, you say about this kind of menacing, the buildup to the Allied invasion, the typhoon of steel was, the Typhoon of Steel was approaching. Typhoon of Steel? We love a gathering storm. That follows the storm clouds of war, right? The Typhoon of Steel? It absolutely does. But, Brett, did I give a correct analysis of
他总是说“纳粹”而不是“纳粹”。纳粹。是的。但我能重新聚焦于《残酷的风暴》吗？因为兄弟，你也提到了这种威胁，盟军入侵前的积聚，钢铁台风正在，钢铁台风正在逼近。钢铁台风？我们喜欢“聚集的风暴”。那是在战争的风暴云之后，对吧？钢铁台风？确实如此。但是，布雷特，我对
kind of the overview of this campaign, that it's meant to be easy, but actually it turns out to be a meat grinder? Yes. So the problem with it is they decide to go into Sicily at the Casablanca Conference in January 1943. And then they have a big update conference called the Trident Conference, which is in May 1943 in Washington. And this is a point where they settle, right, we're absolutely going to make the priority operation overlord, which is going to be the cross-channel invasion,
这场战役的概述是否正确，即它本应很容易，但实际上却变成了一台绞肉机？是的。所以问题在于，他们在1943年1月的卡萨布兰卡会议上决定进入西西里岛。然后他们召开了一个名为“三叉戟会议”的大型更新会议，那是1943年5月在华盛顿举行的。这是他们达成共识的一点，即我们绝对要将“霸王行动”作为优先事项，也就是跨海峡入侵，
which at that point is settled for the 1st of May 1944, but obviously, as we know, ends up being the 6th of June 1944. And the Americans also insist that they're going to accelerate operations in the Pacific against Japan, which is not really what British had imagined playing second fiddle was going to be when they first discussed this on America's entry into the war back in December 1941. But future operations in the Mediterranean, well, they were just going to see what happened, see what happened in Sicily, see whether Sicily did prompt the Italians to get out of the war, see what the situation was and all the rest of it. But Overlord was going to be the absolute priority. And the British agreed to this. They said, okay, fine. Overlord is a priority. And really, the Italian campaign is conducted with the sort of tyranny of overlords sort of overseeing
当时定于1944年5月1日，但正如我们所知，最终变成了1944年6月6日。美国人还坚持要加速在太平洋针对日本的行动，这并不是英国人在1941年12月美国参战时讨论这个问题时所想象的“扮演二等角色”。但地中海的未来行动，嗯，他们只是想看看会发生什么，看看西西里岛会发生什么，看看西西里岛是否真的促使意大利人退出战争，看看局势如何等等。但“霸王行动”将是绝对的优先事项。英国人同意了这一点。他们说，好吧，没问题。“霸王行动”是优先事项。实际上，意大利战役是在“霸王行动”的某种暴政监督下进行的，
everything that they do. And the truth is, despite the kind of incredible rate of shipbuilding, particularly assault craft building, which goes on in the United States and indeed in the UK as well, they simply don't have enough to do all the things they need to do. Because let's not forget, they're also supplying Chiang's nationalists in China at this time. They're also supplying the USSR with vast amounts of supplies as well. Then you've got the Pacific. Then you've got Southeast Asia. Then you've got planning for Overlord, which, you know, by any reckoning is going to be a massive undertaking because it's against the most heavily defended part of the European coastline. So Italy sort of falls in the middle of that. But at the same time, after Sicily, you've got these vast Allied forces in the Mediterranean.
他们所做的一切都在其监督之下。事实是，尽管美国乃至英国在造船方面，特别是突击艇建造方面有着令人难以置信的速度，但他们根本没有足够的资源来完成所有需要做的事情。因为别忘了，他们当时还在向中国的蒋介石国民党提供补给，他们还在向苏联提供大量的补给。然后你有太平洋战场。然后你有东南亚战场。然后你有“霸王行动”的规划，你知道，无论怎么算，这都将是一项艰巨的任务，因为它是针对欧洲海岸线防御最严密的地区。所以意大利在某种程度上处于中间位置。但与此同时，在西西里岛之后，你在地中海拥有庞大的盟军部队。
And it seems crazy not to do anything on land in Europe between then and the 1st of May 1944, when Overlord is originally scheduled. Because the United States has been in the war since the end of 1941. Am I right in saying they've basically cleared the Axis out of North Africa by this point? Yes, they have, absolutely, on the 13th of May 1943. And it's a huge, huge victory. To be perfectly honest, both the British and the Americans have worked out how to beat the Germans by this point, which is by roughly the strategy of steel, not flesh. You use your global reach, huge amounts of mechanisation, firepower, airpower, a sort of brotherhood of air, land, and sea to do the hard yards so that your foot sloggers, the poor bloody infantry, don't have to do so much work. That's the basic idea behind it. And it really works.
如果不做点什么，似乎很疯狂，因为从那时到1944年5月1日（“霸王行动”最初计划的时间）之间，在欧洲陆地上什么都不做。我说得对吗，他们此时基本上已经把轴心国赶出了北非？是的，他们确实做到了，绝对是在1943年5月13日。这是一场巨大、巨大的胜利。老实说，英国人和美国人都已经弄清楚了如何在这个时候击败德国人，那就是通过钢铁而非血肉的战略。你利用你的全球触角、大量的机械化、火力、空中力量，一种海陆空兄弟会来完成艰苦的工作，这样你的步兵，那些可怜的步兵，就不必做那么多工作了。这就是其背后的基本理念。而且它确实有效。
But you're saying that the Allies had too many troops in the Mediterranean to do nothing and very many good strategic reasons to invade Italy, but they didn't have enough to win these prizes easily or even with anything like a guarantee of success. However, they do have a prime minister who has a track record in backing lunatic amphibious schemes. So Churchill famously was the guy who backed the Gallipoli campaign in the First World War that went absolutely disastrously tits up. But here he is again, and he's the great enthusiast for this, isn't he?
但你是说盟军在地中海有太多的部队，什么都不做，而且有很多很好的战略理由入侵意大利，但他们没有足够的资源来轻易赢得这些奖项，甚至没有任何成功的保证。然而，他们确实有一位在支持疯狂的两栖计划方面有前科的首相。所以丘吉尔以支持一战中加里波利战役而闻名，那场战役彻底惨败。但他又来了，他是这个计划的伟大拥护者，不是吗？
And not only invading, but also kind of launching an attack halfway up Italy. Why should we crawl up the leg like a harvest bug from the ankle upwards? Let us rather strike at the knee. Yes. And that's all very pithy and all very well and everything. And he's got very good reasons for saying that actually, because if you look at the toe of Italy, just across from the Straits of Messina, which are so close when you're in Northeast Sicily, that you can almost touch them. I mean, this is the kind of the Straits of Scylla and Charybdis of Homeric Faneborough, of course, but it's incredibly mountainous. And where it's mountainous, obviously, that makes it very difficult for you to pass.
不仅是入侵，而且还在意大利半腰发动攻击。我们为什么要像收获虫一样从脚踝向上爬腿？让我们攻击膝盖吧。是的。这话说得非常精辟，一切都很好。而且他确实有很好的理由这么说，因为如果你看意大利的脚趾，就在墨西拿海峡对面，当你身处西西里岛东北部时，它们是如此之近，以至于你几乎可以触碰到它们。我的意思是，这就是荷马史诗中提到的斯库拉和卡律布狄斯海峡，当然，但它极其多山。而在多山的地方，显然这让你很难通过。
And one of the kind of byproducts of this highly mechanized, highly industrialized type of war that the Allies are kind of protracting is that it comes with lots of vehicles. And the Italian road network is kind of used for Strada Bianca, that kind of dirt roads,, is that it comes with lots of vehicles. And the Italian road network is kind of used for strata bianca, that kind of dirt roads, which are great if you're a kind of horse and cart or the occasional Fiat Topolino, but not so great if you're the 3,000 vehicles of a single infantry division, for example. And divisions are the unit by which we judge the scale of armies in the Second World War. And if you imagine that a division is around 15,000 men, give or take, that's the kind of scale you're talking about. So each 15,000 men strong infantry division would
这种盟军正在进行的这种高度机械化、高度工业化的战争的副产品之一是，它伴随着大量的车辆。而意大利的道路网络在某种程度上被用作“白色道路”（Strada Bianca），那种土路，如果你是马车或偶尔出现的菲亚特Topolino，那很好，但如果你是例如一个步兵师的3000辆车，那就没那么好了。师是我们在二战中衡量军队规模的单位。如果你想象一个师大约有15000人，上下浮动，这就是你所说的规模。所以每个15000人的步兵师会有
have 3,000 vehicles. And you can see how you very quickly can get bogged down in this mountainous terrain, particularly with German engineers blowing up every bridge and mountain pass and culvert along the way. So we've looked at the Allies. They have all this vast preponderance of kit, basically. But could we look at the state of play with the Axis powers? So the Germans and the Italians are allies. They both have fascist leaders, except that in the summer of 1943, Mussolini gets toppled, doesn't he? 25th of July, yeah.
3000辆车。你可以看出，在这种多山的地形中，你很快就会陷入困境，特别是德国工兵在沿途炸毁了每一座桥梁、山口和涵洞。所以我们看了盟军。他们基本上拥有所有这些巨大的装备优势。但我们能看看轴心国的现状吗？所以德国人和意大利人是盟友。他们都有法西斯领导人，除了在1943年夏天，墨索里尼被推翻了，不是吗？7月25日，是的。
So what's happened to him? He's been taken prisoner, right? He's been held in secret. Yes, and he's actually formally deposed by the king on the 26th of July. And it's easy to forget that all through the fascist era, Italy remains a monarchy. And there's King Vittorio Emanuele III, who's a sort of diminutive and rather feckless character, but nonetheless does get rid of Mussolini. And Marshal Pietro Badoglio takes over. He's a rather sort of sad looking fellow and a rather sort of sad character full stop, to be perfectly honest.oglio takes over. He's a rather sad-looking fellow and a rather sad character
那么他发生了什么事？他被俘虏了，对吧？他被秘密关押。是的，他实际上在7月26日被国王正式罢免。很容易忘记，在整个法西斯时代，意大利仍然是一个君主制国家。维托里奥·埃马努埃莱三世国王是一个身材矮小且相当无能的角色，但尽管如此，他确实摆脱了墨索里尼。皮埃特罗·巴多格里奥元帅接管了政权。他是一个看起来相当悲伤的家伙，老实说，他是一个相当悲伤的角色。
if I'll stop, to be perfectly honest. And he takes over as Prime Minister. But if you think Pétain was bad, then Badoglio is even worse. He's just utterly hopeless. And it's absolutely clear that the writing is on the wall, and the Germans know this. And this is one of the big calculations for going into Italy, of course, is that it's not just a question of getting to Rome,
如果我停下来，老实说。他接管了总理职位。但如果你认为贝当很糟糕，那么巴多格里奥更糟。他简直无可救药。而且很明显，大势已去，德国人也知道这一点。当然，这是进入意大利的一个重大考量，因为这不仅仅是到达罗马的问题，
which is what really attracts Churchill to the whole undertaking. The main reason why the Americans buy into it is twofold. Firstly, because it might draw troops away from the Western Front for Operation Overlord. Again, Overlord is a priority, and away from the Eastern Front at the same time. Because Italian troops occupy not just Italy, but also the Balkans and Greece and the Aegean, the Dodecanese, the whole shebang, to a tune of about 32 divisions, which is a huge number of men, which the Germans will have to either abandon or replace it. And they're not going to abandon it because Hitler's extremely paranoid about his southern flank, but also because their only source of real oil that they have at all is in Ploesti and Romania, which is in that realm of the Aegean and the Balkans and all the rest of it. So there's no way they're going to do that. That is part of the Americans and indeed the British calculation for going into Italy. And it is this preoccupation with taking over the Italian armed forces, which dominates German strategy from the moment that Mussolini is overthrown. So outwardly, they're sort of paying lip service to their Italian ally,
这才是真正吸引丘吉尔进行整个行动的原因。美国人接受它的主要原因有两个。首先，因为它可能会将部队从“霸王行动”的西线战场吸引开。同样，“霸王行动”是优先事项，同时也要远离东线战场。因为意大利军队不仅占领了意大利，还占领了巴尔干半岛、希腊、爱琴海、十二群岛，整个摊子，大约有32个师，这是一个巨大的数字，德国人要么必须放弃，要么必须替换。他们不会放弃它，因为希特勒对他的南翼极其偏执，而且因为他们唯一真正的石油来源是在罗马尼亚的普洛耶什蒂，这在爱琴海和巴尔干半岛的范围内。所以他们绝不会那样做。这是美国人乃至英国人进入意大利的考量的一部分。正是这种对接管意大利武装部队的关注，从墨索里尼被推翻的那一刻起，就主导了德国的战略。所以表面上，他们是在向他们的意大利盟友支付口头服务，
but secretly they're plotting to kind of swoop in and take over absolutely everything the moment that the Italians surrender, which they're pretty certain they're going to do. And indeed they are. And meanwhile, there are all kinds of shenanigans going on involving Italian diplomats flying off to Spain and going in disguise and trying to negotiate with British diplomats and so on. But they kind of arrive at a resolution that the Italians will essentially surrender unconditionally. Is that right? Yes. And that is signed at 4.30pm on the 3rd of September, 1943. But what the Allies don't do
但私下里，他们正在策划在意大利投降的那一刻，迅速介入并接管一切，他们非常确定意大利人会这样做。事实上他们确实会。与此同时，各种各样的诡计正在发生，涉及意大利外交官飞往西班牙，乔装打扮，试图与英国外交官谈判等等。但他们最终达成了一个决议，即意大利人将基本上无条件投降。是这样吗？是的。这于1943年9月3日下午4:30签署。但盟军没有做的是
is they tell them that there will be a main invasion somewhere up the leg of Italy, but they don't tell the Italians when that's going to happen or where that's going to happen because the shortage of shipping. And the problem is, is unless you've got a port to go into, you need assault shipping because it's got to go straight onto beaches. So because of the shortness of shipping, they're going to do it in two hits. So they're going to do a very modest eight-farmy crossing with just two divisions, so 30,000 men going across the Straits of Messina into the tow to kind of sort of distract the Germans and the Italians and all the rest. Which they do on the 3rd of September, the same day as the armistice is announced.
他们告诉他们，在意大利的腿部某个地方会有一次主要的入侵，但他们没有告诉意大利人这会在什么时候发生，或者会在哪里发生，因为缺乏航运。问题是，除非你有一个港口可以进入，否则你需要突击航运，因为它必须直接进入海滩。所以由于航运的短缺，他们将分两次进行。所以他们将进行一次非常温和的第八集团军跨越，只有两个师，即30000人穿过墨西拿海峡进入脚趾，以某种方式分散德国人和意大利人的注意力等等。他们在9月3日，即宣布停战的同一天做到了这一点。
Very same day. So early that morning that the surrender has been signed, they have gone in. And that's one of the reasons why the Italians sign it, because clearly the allies are serious, because they've already crossed the Strait of Messina. But on that same day, they promise that there's going to be a subsequent bigger invasion somewhere else. And the Italians get it into their head that it's going to be in the middle of September, and it's going to be somewhere around Rome. But anyone who knows anything about modern warfare would know that you can't do an amphibious invasion without air cover and that Rome is just simply too far from allied bases in Sicily and Malta and so on. So that's a ludicrous
就在同一天。所以就在投降签署的那天清晨，他们已经进去了。这也是意大利人签署它的原因之一，因为很明显盟军是认真的，因为他们已经越过了墨西拿海峡。但在同一天，他们承诺在其他地方会有随后的更大规模的入侵。意大利人认为这会在9月中旬发生，而且会在罗马附近。但任何了解现代战争的人都知道，没有空中掩护是不可能进行两栖入侵的，而且罗马距离盟军在西西里岛和马耳他的基地太远了。所以这是一个荒谬的
presumption and there is no reason at all why the allies would land in the middle of September. So this is just a kind of false assumption by the Italians, but plays havoc with what happens subsequently. So you're a military historian, you're not a historian of Italy, but... A historian of war, Dominic. A historian of war, not a military historian. What's the difference? A massive difference, because military is just about brigades and divisions and stuff, whereas a war historian is about everything, economic, political, social, the whole shebang.
假设，没有任何理由盟军会在9月中旬登陆。所以这只是意大利人的一种错误假设，但对随后发生的事情造成了严重破坏。所以你是一位军事历史学家，你不是意大利历史学家，但是……一位战争历史学家，多米尼克。一位战争历史学家，而不是军事历史学家。有什么区别？巨大的区别，因为军事只是关于旅、师之类的东西，而战争历史学家是关于一切，经济、政治、社会，整个摊子。
Tom, did you know this? Yeah, I did. Of course I did. I don't believe you. 500 episodes, you've never mentioned it. A military historian is retired Colonel Smithers. He's written a book about the 3rd Brigade in Dunkirk in 1940 or something. So James, what do people in Italy think of all this?
汤姆，你知道这个吗？是的，我知道。我当然知道。我不相信你。500集了，你从来没提过。军事历史学家是退休的史密瑟斯上校。他写了一本关于1940年敦刻尔克第三旅的书之类的东西。所以詹姆斯，意大利的人们怎么看这一切？
So ordinary Italians, they were in the war. They were on the side of the Axis. They're all going, oh, let's build a new empire. It's all gone horribly wrong in North Africa. Suddenly, armistice. Messolini has been out of action for months. An armistice plus the Allies are now landing. What does Roberto Donadoni, I mean, obviously he played for Italy in 1990,
所以普通的意大利人，他们参加了战争。他们站在轴心国一边。他们都在说，哦，让我们建立一个新帝国。在北非一切都变得非常糟糕。突然，停战。墨索里尼已经几个月没参与行动了。停战加上盟军现在正在登陆。罗伯托·多纳多尼会怎么想，我的意思是，显然他在1990年为意大利效力，
so I don't know why he's alive in 1943. But had he been? He's in the time travel machine. Yeah, exactly. What does the Roberto Donadoni of 1943 think of this? Well, most Italians are absolutely ecstatic about it and think that this means the war is over. Of course, the Italian leadership don't realise
所以我不知道为什么他在1943年还活着。但如果他活着呢？他在时间机器里。是的，完全正确。1943年的罗伯托·多纳多尼会怎么想？嗯，大多数意大利人对此感到非常狂喜，认为这意味着战争结束了。当然，意大利领导层没有意识到
that they're between a rock and a hard place because, you know, get it wrong with the Germans, they're all going to be rounded up and executed. But on the other hand, they want the Allies to come to their rescue and it's a very difficult line to juggle. But, bro, just to intrude, because I love this detail so much, the Germans have flooded Italy, haven't they, with German troops, and they call this Operation Alaric, after the Gothic leader who sacks Rome. Yep. I love that.
他们处于进退两难的境地，因为，你知道，如果和德国人搞砸了，他们都会被围捕并处决。但另一方面，他们希望盟军来拯救他们，这是一条非常难走的钢丝。但是，兄弟，插一句，因为我太喜欢这个细节了，德国人用德国军队淹没了意大利，不是吗？他们称之为“阿拉里克行动”，以洗劫罗马的哥特领袖命名。是的。我喜欢那个。
They do. And then there's a different one. It's Constantine for Greece and the Balkans, but then beginning of September, Hitler changes his name to just Operation Axis, which is wonderfully ironic as well. But yes, most Italians are absolutely delighted about it. And even once the Allies do land and get a foothold in Italy and start sort of destroying vast numbers of villages and towns, they're still sort of cheering them as they're coming into the towns. I mean, the bottom line is, is they're absolutely impoverished and they're just absolutely had it up to here with the war. They're just not interested anymore. But James, are these not the same people who two years earlier would have been cheering the news of Italian advances and Italian victories? Absolutely.
他们确实这样做了。然后还有一个不同的。那是希腊和巴尔干半岛的“君士坦丁行动”，但到了9月初，希特勒将名字改为“轴心行动”，这也非常具有讽刺意味。但是的，大多数意大利人对此感到非常高兴。即使在盟军登陆并在意大利站稳脚跟并开始摧毁大量村庄和城镇之后，当他们进入城镇时，他们仍然在为他们欢呼。我的意思是，底线是，他们已经彻底贫困了，他们对战争已经受够了。他们只是不再感兴趣了。但詹姆斯，这些人不就是两年前还在为意大利的进展和胜利欢呼的同一群人吗？绝对是。
I mean, have they just turned their coats? Yep, they turned very quickly. And I mean, without wanting to sort of be sweeping in my judgment of Italians, I do remember talking to some Sicilians and, you know, them saying that when the Americans arrived in Gela in southern Sicily, they were very suspicious and thought, you know, Mussolini's going to triumph. And then literally a day later, they were going around sort of handing out chocolate and cigarettes. And they thought, oh, Americans are absolutely brilliant. Mussolini's rubbish. And just turned just like that on a sixpence. And a friend of mine who was with me at the time, who actually lived in Sicily, said, that's just so Italian.
我的意思是，他们只是变节了吗？是的，他们转变得非常快。而且，我不想对意大利人做出笼统的评价，但我确实记得和一些西西里人交谈，他们说当美国人到达西西里南部的杰拉时，他们非常怀疑，认为，你知道，墨索里尼会获胜。然后仅仅一天后，他们就在四处分发巧克力和香烟。他们想，哦，美国人太棒了。墨索里尼是垃圾。就这样瞬间改变了。当时和我在一起的一个朋友，他实际上住在西西里岛，说，这太意大利了。
They'll sort of back the winner. And they felt by 1943, second half of 1943, that the winners were the Allies, not the Germans. And frankly, they were right. And so they just completely had it with the war. They'd had it with fascism. They'd had it with everything. The whole point about fascism was it was supposed to make them feel better and good about themselves and richer and more prosperous. And so when that doesn't happen, understandably, they turned. I mean, it's a bit like kind of everyone's all for Boris when he wins the election, but how quickly it crumbled when they realised how feckless and hopeless he was.
他们会支持赢家。他们觉得到了1943年，1943年下半年，赢家是盟军，而不是德国人。坦率地说，他们是对的。所以他们彻底受够了战争。他们受够了法西斯主义。他们受够了一切。法西斯主义的全部意义在于它应该让他们感觉更好，对自己感觉良好，更富有，更繁荣。所以当这种情况没有发生时，可以理解，他们转变了。我的意思是，这有点像鲍里斯赢得选举时每个人都支持他，但当他们意识到他有多么无能和绝望时，这种支持崩溃得有多快。
Right. So, I mean, not comparing the Italian leadership in the Second World War to Boris. Well, there's a certain similarity between him and Mussolini, I'd say. Yeah, why don't we? The mistake that you've made is you think we're the rest is politics. They love that kind of chat on the rest is politics. We enjoy it within reason. So the Italian leadership are basically very unimpressive.
对。所以，我的意思是，没有把二战中的意大利领导层与鲍里斯相提并论。嗯，我觉得他和墨索里尼之间有一定的相似之处。是的，为什么不呢？你犯的错误是你以为我们是《历史的政治》（The Rest Is Politics）。他们喜欢在《历史的政治》中进行那种聊天。我们在合理的范围内享受它。所以意大利领导层基本上非常令人印象深刻。
Oh my God, are they ever. I mean, the Allies want to get rid of the king. They don't trust Badoglio and they've surrendered unconditionally. And the whole thing is essentially a shambles. And the Italians think that the Allies are not going to evade until September. September the 12th, I think, are the earliest. Yeah. Right.
天哪，他们确实如此。我的意思是，盟军想摆脱国王。他们不信任巴多格里奥，而且他们已经无条件投降了。整个事情基本上是一团糟。意大利人认为盟军直到9月才会入侵。我想最早是9月12日。是的。对。
In the event, the main invasion happened six days after the Allies have crossed the Straits of Messina in the south. Yeah. And it is south of Salerno. Yes. Which again is south of Naples. So it's kind of pretty much in the middle. And this is called Operation Avalanche. It's launched on the 9th of September.
事实上，主要入侵发生在盟军越过墨西拿海峡六天后。是的。而且是在萨莱诺以南。是的，这也就在那不勒斯以南。所以它基本上就在中间。这被称为“雪崩行动”。它于9月9日发起。
You describe it as being an almighty and totally out of character gamble. So in what way is it a gamble? In what way is it out of character? Again, they just don't have enough shipping. So I know Dominic loves statistics and loves me mentioning trucks and things. He does. I like facts. I do like facts. They're very grindy in that way. Okay. Well, let me give you some facts. So for Operation Husky, which is Invasion of Sicily, they have 1,743 landing craft and sail craft. And these are ones that can just go straight onto a beach. So you don't need a port. You can just go straight in, down comes a ramp, off they go. For Operation Baytown, which is the crossing of the Straits of Messina, they have 268. For Avalanche, they have 359. So 359 for an operation where they are against
你将其描述为一场全能且完全不符合性格的赌博。那么它在什么方面是赌博？它在什么方面不符合性格？同样，他们只是没有足够的航运。所以我知道多米尼克喜欢统计数据，喜欢我提到卡车之类的东西。他确实喜欢。我喜欢事实。我确实喜欢事实。它们在这方面非常枯燥。好吧。让我给你一些事实。所以对于“哈士奇行动”，也就是入侵西西里岛，他们有1743艘登陆艇和帆船。这些是可以直接进入海滩的。所以你不需要港口。你可以直接进去，坡道下来，他们就出发了。对于“海湾城镇行动”，也就是越过墨西拿海峡，他们有268艘。对于“雪崩行动”，他们有359艘。所以359艘用于一场他们面对
19 German divisions in Italy at that point, compared to the two that were opposing them in Sicily. And what that means is the lack of landing craft. It's not just a question of getting them there at H hour on D-Day, the kind of first moment of the evasion. These landing craft are in action the whole time, just shuttling forth troops and ammunition and supplies and all the rest of it. They're absolutely vital to the whole thing.
当时意大利19个德国师的行动，相比之下，在西西里岛只有两个师反对他们。这意味着缺乏登陆艇。这不仅仅是在D日的H小时，即入侵的第一时刻把他们送到那里的问题。这些登陆艇一直在行动，只是来回运送部队、弹药、补给等等。它们对整个事情绝对至关重要。
So where are the troops coming from, from Sicily? Yes, they're mainly coming from Sicily and from Algeria. And they're coming in troop ships and then the infantry go in their landing craft. But there's also the little Higgins boats and the LCAs and all the rest of it. What is an LCA? It's a landing craft assault. They can take sort of 36 men, but then you have these large ones, which are landing ships, which are much bigger. Okay. And they can do this because they have air power? They can do this because you have air power. And they could just about get air power north of Naples, but your Spitfires or whatever wouldn't be able to linger long enough over the beaches to be properly effective. And so because of the shortage of landing craft, they're having to up
那么部队是从哪里来的，从西西里岛吗？是的，他们主要来自西西里岛和阿尔及利亚。他们乘坐运兵船，然后步兵乘坐他们的登陆艇进入。但还有小希金斯船和LCA等等。什么是LCA？它是突击登陆艇。它们可以搭载大约36人，但你还有大型的，也就是登陆舰，它们大得多。好的。他们能做到这一点是因为他们有空中力量？他们能做到这一点是因为你有空中力量。他们勉强能在那不勒斯以北获得空中力量，但你的喷火战斗机或其他飞机将无法在海滩上停留足够长的时间以发挥真正的作用。而且由于登陆艇的短缺，他们不得不提升
the game with naval warships and naval gunpower, but also with aircraft. But even that is just not enough. So what that means is the Allies are only aircraft. But even that is just not enough. So what that means is the Allies are only able to land on D-Day three divisions. So what's that, you know, 45,000 men, plus two groups of special forces, the commandos and the US Army ragers up in the north and the sort of Amalfi Coast to go and secure some passes. But that is really, really undercooked, again, compared to Husky. Now, obviously, Sicily is larger, but it is amazing how small the initial landing is when one considers the challenge, the height that they are up the leg of Italy, and how many German troops there are on Italy at that time.
海军军舰和海军炮火的游戏，还有飞机。但即使这样也还不够。所以这意味着盟军在D日只能登陆三个师。所以那是，你知道，45000人，加上两组特种部队，北部的突击队和美国陆军游骑兵，以及阿马尔菲海岸去确保一些山口。但那真的，真的准备不足，再次相比“哈士奇行动”。现在，显然，西西里岛更大，但当人们考虑到挑战、他们深入意大利腿部的程度以及当时意大利有多少德国军队时，最初的登陆规模之小令人惊讶。
Now, there's only actually one German division directly facing them where they're landing. But it's only a matter of time before those other divisions start to sort of coalesce around Salerno. That's the issue. And so the fighting is very hard. And at one point, it looks as though the Allies are going to be basically flung back into the sea. And the commanders are talking about the possibility of retreat. But they fight on in the face of large German numbers. And they have a secret weapon, don't they? The Fritz X. So what is the Fritz X? So the Fritz X is the first ever kind of radio controlled guided missile. It's a very sort of sophisticated and clever piece of kit. The guy who's guiding it is on a Dornier, which is a sort
现在，实际上只有一支德国师直接面对他们登陆的地方。但那些其他师开始在萨莱诺周围聚集只是时间问题。这就是问题所在。所以战斗非常艰难。有一次，看起来盟军基本上要被扔回海里。指挥官们正在谈论撤退的可能性。但他们在面对大量德国军队的情况下继续战斗。他们有一个秘密武器，不是吗？弗里茨X。那么什么是弗里茨X？所以弗里茨X是第一种无线电控制的制导导弹。它是一种非常复杂和聪明的装备。引导它的人在多尼尔飞机上，这是一种
of twin engine bomber. So it's a bit like a drone, is it? It's a bit like a drone, yeah. Effectively, it is an unmanned aerial vehicle, I would say. And he has to have visual contact on it the whole time. So he's on the Dornier. You release it from the sort of mothership and off it goes. And he can control it as long as he can see it. And it's obviously packed with explosives and it's specifically designed to get through sort of battleships and cruisers. So it's very effective. Okay. But in the end, allied air and naval power proves overwhelming. Yes. And the brilliance of the infantry on the ground. And the beach is secured. Yep. Yep. Salerno is secured.
双引擎轰炸机。所以它有点像无人机，是吗？它有点像无人机，是的。实际上，我会说它是一架无人驾驶飞行器。他必须一直保持对它的视觉接触。所以他在多尼尔飞机上。你从母舰上释放它，它就出发了。只要他能看到它，他就可以控制它。它显然装满了炸药，它是专门为穿透战列舰和巡洋舰而设计的。所以它非常有效。好的。但最终，盟军的空中和海军力量证明是压倒性的。是的。还有地面步兵的才华。海滩被确保了。是的。是的。萨莱诺被确保了。
Right. So from my point of view, the most interesting thing about all this is that it is taking place around the three most significant surviving Doric temples from the golden age of Greece. So I found loads about the book, which is wonderfully, horribly written. Endless, grueling details. Horribly written. I can't believe you just said that. The sense of horror that it conveys. I didn't take it that way, Dominic, don't worry. The deeper sense of horror it gave me was the endless description of how close all these classical ruins come to being left even more ruined so you have an american corporal who records in his diary came about one mile inland he then adds moved again to some ancient ruins and these are the three great what the heck were they greek temples the doric temple
对。所以从我的角度来看，关于这一切最有趣的事情是，它发生在希腊黄金时代幸存的三座最重要的多立克神庙周围。所以我发现了大量关于这本书的内容，它写得非常精彩，也非常可怕。无尽的、令人筋疲力尽的细节。写得太可怕了。我不敢相信你刚才说了那个。它传达的恐怖感。我不是那样理解的，多米尼克，别担心。它给我的更深层的恐怖感是对所有这些古典遗迹如何差点被留得更加残破的无尽描述，所以你有一个美国下士在他的日记中记录，向内陆移动了大约一英里，他接着补充说，再次移动到一些古代遗迹，这些是三座伟大的，到底是什么，希腊神庙，多立克神庙
at paestum and basically they set up camp in the middle of ancient paestum don't they they do they kind of use the walls as a defense so that that's very, very chilling. And meanwhile, while this is going on, the Germans are seizing control in Rome and driving panzers down. And you describe how they're kind of aiming their guns at the Arch of Constantine and the Colosseum. And the whole thing is, I think if you have any familiarity with ancient or medieval history, The fact that all these battles are taking place in all these kinds of contexts. And it's obviously of appeal to the commanders themselves, isn't it? So we talked about how the Germans have Operation Alaric. And you've talked later about how General Allenbrook is flying over Southern Italy en route to a meeting with
在帕埃斯图姆，基本上他们在古代帕埃斯图姆的中间建立了营地，不是吗？他们确实这样做了，他们把墙壁用作防御，所以这非常，非常令人不寒而栗。与此同时，当这一切发生时，德国人正在夺取罗马的控制权并驾驶装甲车南下。你描述了他们如何将枪口对准君士坦丁凯旋门和斗兽场。我认为如果你对古代或中世纪历史有任何了解，这一切都是如此。事实上，所有这些战斗都发生在所有这些背景中。这显然对指挥官们自己有吸引力，不是吗？所以我们谈到了德国人有“阿拉里克行动”。你后来谈到了艾伦布鲁克将军在飞往与蒙哥马利会面的途中飞越意大利南部。
Montgomery. And he orders his plane to make a gentle loop around the battleground of Cannae, which was the great victory won by Hannibal against the Roman Republic. So there's a lot going on there. There are lots of echoes and shades. Well, I have to admit, when I was out there kind of sort of walking the ground and looking at the distance between the landing beaches and where they were and thinking about the Americans setting up their base camp within the old city walls of Paistop,
他命令他的飞机在坎尼战场上绕了一个轻柔的圈，那是汉尼拔对罗马共和国取得的伟大胜利。所以那里发生了很多事情。有很多回声和阴影。嗯，我必须承认，当我在那里走在地面上，看着登陆海滩和他们所在位置之间的距离，并思考美国人在帕埃斯图姆古城墙内建立基地营地时，
I was thinking of Ibro and thinking how upset you'd be about the whole thing. And ditto when Carlo Caponi was dodging the tank shells in Rome and going towards the Forum and all the rest of it. I mean, it's just amazing, isn't it? It shows just what a sort of incredible history Italy has and that all these places end up repeatedly being caught up in successive wars and so much destruction. Well, thankfully, the Arch of Constantine survives. The Germans secure Rome
我在想兄弟，想着你会对整件事有多么不安。同样，当卡洛·卡波尼在罗马躲避坦克炮弹并走向广场等等时。我的意思是，这太神奇了，不是吗？它展示了意大利拥有多么令人难以置信的历史，所有这些地方最终都反复陷入连续的战争和如此多的破坏中。嗯，谢天谢地，君士坦丁凯旋门幸存了下来。德国人确保了罗马
and basically take it over. And the temples in Paestum survive as well. Don't get any damage at all, remarkably. That's extraordinary. No, huge relief all round. I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, let's look at what the long-term effects over the rest of 1943 are of the Allies securing this bridgehead. We'll see you in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
并基本上接管了它。帕埃斯图姆的神庙也幸存了下来。非常引人注目的是，它们根本没有受到任何损坏。这太非凡了。不，到处都是巨大的解脱。我想我们应该在这一点上休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们看看盟军确保这个桥头堡对1943年余下时间的长远影响。几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. In no other theatre was more demanded of Allied frontline troops. They were not being supplied with the normal levels of materiel or replacements. The conditions were appalling. The mud, the rain, the freezing temperatures, disease.
这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开了娱乐的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。在其他任何战区，对盟军前线部队的要求都没有这么高。他们没有得到正常水平的物资或补充。条件极其恶劣。泥泞、雨水、冰冻的温度、疾病。
The inability to deploy armour, mechanisation and air power. In the valley floor, the mud was knee-deep. Even in the jungle or on Pacific atolls, the men could at least dig in. In the mountains, the soil was thin or non-existent, making mortars and shells even more lethal and shelter harder to come by. So that is from The Savage Storm by top presenter of We Have Ways of Making You Talk and historian of the Second World War. Not a military historian, but a historian of war. And the way you read that, Dominic, it makes it sound not horrible at all. Right. Oh, that's nice. That's good to hear.
无法部署装甲、机械化和空中力量。在山谷底部，泥浆没过膝盖。即使在丛林或太平洋环礁上，士兵们至少可以挖掩体。在山上，土壤很薄或根本不存在，这使得迫击炮和炮弹更加致命，掩体也更难找到。所以这是来自《残酷的风暴》，作者是《我们有办法让你开口》的顶级主持人，也是二战历史学家。不是军事历史学家，而是战争历史学家。你读它的方式，多米尼克，让它听起来一点也不可怕。对。哦，那很好。很高兴听到这个。
Not horribly written. I thought it sounded pretty bad. Well, horribly written was your brother's verdict in the first half. So viewers can make up their own minds about that. I was thinking, gosh, that's actually quite nicely written, that bit. It conveys the horror, doesn't it? That's the beauty of a really good reading. A lot of that is in the narrator's voice, I think you'll find.
写得并不糟糕。我以为它听起来很糟糕。嗯，写得太可怕了是你兄弟在上半场的结论。所以观众可以自己决定。我在想，天哪，那部分其实写得很好。它传达了恐怖，不是吗？这就是真正好的阅读的美妙之处。我想你会发现，其中很多都在叙述者的声音里。
Absolutely. I question the break. Right. Listen, let's talk about what is going on particularly in naples yes that great city so naples is kind of the epicenter of the action yeah the germans have been in naples but they've now decided they're going to have to pull out is that right yes phil marshall kessering who is the commander of german forces the southern half of italy and subsequently becomes the commander of all german troops in italy when he realizes that they're're not going to win at Salerno, he calls a general retreat back to the river Volterno, which is about 25 miles north of Naples. So when they're retreating, they don't just scurry back there overnight. It's a kind of delaying action, kind of fighting retreat, etc. But Naples falls
绝对。我质疑休息。对。听着，让我们谈谈特别是在那不勒斯发生的事情，是的，那座伟大的城市，所以那不勒斯是行动的中心，是的，德国人在那不勒斯，但他们现在决定他们必须撤出，是这样吗？是的，凯塞林元帅，他是意大利南部德国军队的指挥官，随后在意识到他们不会在萨莱诺获胜时，成为意大利所有德国军队的指挥官，他下令全面撤退到沃尔图诺河，那在那不勒斯以北约25英里处。所以当他们撤退时，他们不仅仅是连夜匆忙撤回那里。这是一种拖延行动，某种战斗撤退等等。但那不勒斯沦陷了
into that. And don't they also, they have a thing where they have allied prisoners of war and they kind of lead them in a Roman-style triumph through the streets of Naples. Yes. Well, that's before Naples has fought to try and sort of keep the Neapolitans in check. They're terribly worried about having a revolt in Naples because obviously, you know, the last thing they want to do is have to be dealing with that as well as the enemies. I should just say very quickly though, before we get to Naples, I mean, Kesselring has really, really copped things up in a massive way because his plan is once he's wrapped up Rome, which he does on the 10th of September, so the day after Avalanche is launched, he then sends all his available divisions, which are eight in total,
深入探讨。他们是不是还有一种做法，就是把盟军战俘像罗马凯旋式那样押着游街，穿过那不勒斯的大街小巷？是的。不过那是在那不勒斯开战之前，他们试图以此来震慑那不勒斯人。他们非常担心那不勒斯会发生起义，因为显然，他们最不想看到的就是在应对敌人的同时还要处理这种麻烦。不过，在谈到那不勒斯之前，我得赶紧说一下，凯塞林在这一块儿搞得一团糟，因为他的计划是，一旦他拿下了罗马——他在9月10日做到了，也就是“雪崩”行动发起后的第二天——他就把所有能调动的师，总共八个师，
down towards Salerno. And the idea is to put everything he possibly can, throw all his eggs in one basket, chuck the Allies out into the sea, then turn to eight farming in the toe of Italy, tidy it all up and all the rest of it. And then the whole of southern Italy will be back in German's hands and the Allies won't be able to secure a toehold at all. That's the plan. But by chucking all his eggs in one basket and then failing, he's left himself fatally weak in the southern part of Italy, particularly the southeast of Italy.
全部派往萨莱诺。他的想法是孤注一掷，把所有筹码都押上，把盟军赶下海，然后再转头去处理意大利“靴尖”地区的防御，把一切收拾妥当。这样一来，整个意大利南部就会回到德国人手中，盟军将无法在意大利立足。这就是他的计划。但由于他孤注一掷却最终失败，他在意大利南部，特别是东南部，陷入了致命的兵力空虚。
And three big ports, Taranto, Bari and Brindisi, the British are able to just walk into because they don't need assault craft for those because they're open ports. And so they can just sell their ships straight in and put on the quayside. And he hasn't got enough troops left in Southeast Italy to maintain that. And so what that means is that actually one of the main reasons for the Allies going into Italy in the first place, which was, again, all part of Operation Overlord, but is securing the airfield complex around Foggia, which is around two-fifths of the way up on the Adriatic side in one of the very rare flat bits of Italy. That falls on the 27th of September, so five days before Naples does,
塔兰托、巴里和布林迪西这三个大港口，英军几乎是不费吹灰之力就进驻了，因为这些是开放港口，不需要登陆艇。所以他们可以直接把船开进去，停靠在码头边。而他在意大利东南部已经没有足够的兵力来维持防线了。这意味着，盟军最初进入意大利的主要原因之一——这同样是“霸王行动”的一部分——即确保福贾周围的机场群，也就是亚得里亚海一侧、意大利为数不多的平原地区之一，在9月27日就落入了盟军手中，比那不勒斯早了五天，
and is an absolute shoo-in. I mean, it's basically given up without a fight and is one of the most important bits of real estate in the whole southern half of Italy. So at that point, there's absolutely no point at all in even defending south of Rome because, okay, you lose Rome, but it's frankly neither here nor there at that point. It is a huge own goal. But unfortunately, his inverted commas determined defence at Salerno has brought Hitler's attention, which is why he ends up being ultimate supremo in Italy. But with Hitler's attention comes the Hitlerian spotlight, and that then absolutely restricts your room for manoeuvre, which is why he is then consigned to fight as far south as Rome
而且几乎没费什么力气。可以说，那里基本上是不战而降，是整个意大利南部最重要的地盘之一。所以在那一点上，防守罗马以南地区已经毫无意义了，因为好吧，你丢了罗马，但坦率地说，在那时那已经无关紧要了。这是一个巨大的乌龙。但不幸的是，他在萨莱诺那所谓的“坚决防御”引起了希特勒的注意，这就是为什么他最终成为了意大利战区的最高统帅。但希特勒的关注也带来了“希特勒聚光灯效应”，这绝对限制了他的回旋余地，这就是为什么他随后被要求尽可能在罗马以南进行防御。
as he possibly can. But that's just to sort of give you that whole perspective and why actually three out of the four reasons for the Allies going in, i.e. getting Italy out of the war, tick, drawing in German troops, massive tick, getting the Foggia airfield complex, huge tick. That's all happened in very, very quick order. The only thing that eludes them is the capital, which of course is the thing that Churchill's obsessed about. But because they've got Foggia, and because it's so important to them, and this tightening the air power noose around Nazi Germany is so vital, you've got to protect it. You don't want to have that. Put all the effort
但这只是为了让你了解整个背景，以及为什么盟军进入意大利的四个理由中有三个——即让意大利退出战争（达成），牵制德军（巨大成功），获得福贾机场群（巨大成功）——都很快实现了。唯一没能实现的就是占领首都，当然，那也是丘吉尔最执着的目标。但因为他们拿下了福贾，而且这对他们来说太重要了，这种对纳粹德国的空中绞索收紧至关重要，你必须保护它。你不想投入所有努力
into getting bomb groups and all the rest of it and fuel dumps and blah, blah, blah over to Foggia and then lose it again. So you need a cushion. So that's why the Allies are then compelled to absolutely stay on the job and push north of Rome. And at the same time, the Germans, because Hitler's spotlight is now on them, are now also compelled to fight south of Rome. So this is why it becomes this huge almighty clash. Isn't it also that they're very anxious about the idea of a replica of the Western Front in the First World War, that they don't want a stationary war? Yeah, absolutely. But sorry, that was a slight divert. Just to go back to Naples. So Naples is the third biggest city. It's a population around 900,000 people. It's the most densely
去建立轰炸机群、燃料库等等，结果又把它丢了。所以你需要一个缓冲地带。这就是为什么盟军被迫必须坚持下去，并向罗马以北推进。与此同时，德国人因为希特勒的聚光灯现在照在他们身上，也被迫在罗马以南作战。所以这就是为什么这里变成了一场巨大的冲突。他们是不是也非常担心重演第一次世界大战的西线战场，不想打阵地战？是的，绝对是。但抱歉，刚才稍微跑题了。回到那不勒斯。那不勒斯是第三大城市，人口约90万。它是意大利人口最稠密的
populated city as well in Italy. It has also been bombed over 180 times by the Allies since the start of the war and 175 times since the start of 1943. And it's much damage done to its archaeological treasures. Much, much damage. And what about Pompeii? Yeah, Pompeii is also damaged, I'm sorry to say. But it is looked after, curated by a very efficient fascist archaeologist and curator who does a brilliant job in safeguarding it as much as he possibly can. You'll be pleased to know.
城市。自战争开始以来，它已被盟军轰炸了180多次，自1943年初以来就轰炸了175次。其考古宝藏遭到了严重破坏。非常、非常严重的破坏。那庞贝古城呢？是的，很遗憾，庞贝也受到了破坏。但它由一位非常高效的法西斯考古学家和馆长照看，他在保护古迹方面做得非常出色，尽了他所能。你会很高兴知道这一点。
Well, thank goodness for that. So the conditions in the city are absolutely appalling. Absolutely appalling. Near famine, effectively. Completely. So it's partly because of the Allied bombing, but it's also partly because of the scorched earth policy that the Germans have. This is for two reasons. Mainly, it is to try and slow up the Allies. So if the Allies have got to look after a humanitarian crisis, then that's going to slow up their advance and make life difficult for them. So that's the main reason for doing it. Second reason is spitefulness because they got stabbed in the back, etc. So what they do is they have an exclusion zone of 300 metres from the waterfront all around the port facilities and destroy everything they possibly can. All the water systems, the water network is destroyed, the electricity network is destroyed. They damage as many water of water wells and all the rest of it as they possibly can. And the whole place is just
好吧，谢天谢地。所以城里的情况简直糟透了。简直糟透了。实际上接近饥荒。完全是这样。这部分是因为盟军的轰炸，但也部分是因为德国人实行的焦土政策。这有两个原因。主要是为了试图拖慢盟军的脚步。如果盟军必须处理人道主义危机，那就会拖慢他们的推进速度，给他们制造困难。所以这是主要原因。第二个原因是出于恶意，因为他们被背叛了等等。所以他们做的是，在港口设施周围300米范围内划定禁区，并摧毁他们能摧毁的一切。所有的供水系统、水网都被摧毁了，电力网络也被摧毁了。他们尽可能多地破坏水井等等。整个地方简直就是
an absolute mashup. And there is a humanitarian crisis in Naples. It's absolutely horrific. And so what does this mean for the Neapolitans? How do they cope? Well, it means starvation. Also, the other problem is that the Allies, as they move up northwards, they create what's called Allied Military Government of Occupied Territories, AMGOT. And of course, the conditions for this are sort of dreamt up by desk wallers in Allied Forces headquarters in Algiers, by people who don't really know Italy and don't really understand it. There's a bit of spitefulness going on there as well. The exchange rate is set too high. There's chronic inflation. There's lots of black marketeering going on it is absolutely wretched for people but also james
一片废墟。那不勒斯正处于人道主义危机之中。这简直太可怕了。那么这对那不勒斯人意味着什么？他们如何应对？这意味着饥饿。此外，另一个问题是，盟军在向北推进时，建立了所谓的“盟军被占领土军政府”（AMGOT）。当然，这些条件是由阿尔及尔盟军总部的文职人员构想出来的，他们并不真正了解意大利，也不真正理解它。这其中也夹杂着一些恶意。汇率定得太高。出现了严重的通货膨胀。黑市交易猖獗，对民众来说简直苦不堪言，但詹姆斯，
surely the allies think i mean the italians a they've been fighting us and killing our boys until very very recently but b they joined the war like kind of hyenas at the feast when they thought hitler was going to win now they're feeling sorry for themselves but they brought this on themselves are not a lot of allies thinking that well there is a bit of that going on but what you tend to find with a lot of the allies is they have this sort of preconceived view of italy certainly which goes very much along those lines and then they get to italy and befriend some italians and you know they see this sort of lovely warm open population and sort of you know the classic italian character and all the rest of it
盟军肯定会想，意大利人直到最近还在和我们作战，杀害我们的士兵，而且他们加入战争就像在盛宴中闻到血腥味的鬣狗，当他们以为希特勒会赢的时候就加入了。现在他们感到自怜，但这是他们自找的，难道没有很多盟军士兵这么想吗？确实有这种想法。但你往往会发现，很多盟军士兵对意大利有一种先入为主的看法，确实很大程度上是沿着这些思路的，然后他们到了意大利，结识了一些意大利人，你知道，他们看到了这种可爱、热情、开放的民众，以及那种经典的意大利性格等等，
and are quickly seduced i mean a lot of people who know anything about italy in the second world war would have heard of norman lewis's great diary that he kept called naples 44 and it's a brilliantly vivid account of someone who absolutely has his humanity very much intact and is just sort of destroyed by what he sees and the kind of awful tragedy he witnesses. I mean, you know, it's been amazing seeing all the footage of Gaza and the poor old Gazans and, you know, how much are they responsible for Hamas and how much are they just innocent people wanting to get on with their lives? You know, these are the sort of questions that one asks oneself.
很快就被吸引了。我的意思是，任何了解二战意大利的人都会听说过诺曼·刘易斯写的伟大日记《那不勒斯44》，这是一部极其生动的记录，作者的人性完全未泯，却被他所见到的景象和那种可怕的悲剧所摧毁。我的意思是，你知道，看到所有关于加沙的镜头和那些可怜的加沙人，你知道，他们对哈马斯负有多少责任，而他们中又有多少人只是想过正常生活的无辜平民？你知道，这些就是人们会问自己的问题。
And, you know, when you're looking at Naples and Italy, it's not just Naples. I mean, you know, around the battlefield of Salerno, Salerno is pretty bashed about, but Eberle, Atavilla, Battapaglia, these towns are all absolutely just wiped from the face of the earth. And plenty more will be before the war finally finishes in Italy. The levels and scales of destruction are absolutely appalling. And I think one of the things one has to understand is in such a mountainous country, most of the population, and Italy has a population of around 40 million, so it's one of the more populated countries in Europe. Most of them, of course, are on exactly the same arteries. Most of the habitation cities are on the same arteries that the Allies are trying to advance up and the Germans are trying to retreat down. And this is the difference with North Africa,
而且，你知道，当你审视那不勒斯和意大利时，不仅仅是那不勒斯。我的意思是，你知道，在萨莱诺战场周围，萨莱诺被炸得相当惨，但埃博利、阿塔维拉、巴塔帕利亚，这些城镇简直从地球表面被抹去了。在意大利战争最终结束之前，还会有更多城镇遭遇同样的命运。破坏的程度和规模简直令人震惊。我认为人们必须理解的一点是，在一个如此多山的国家，大部分人口——意大利有大约4000万人口，所以它是欧洲人口较多的国家之一——大部分人当然都居住在相同的交通干线上。大多数居住城市都在盟军试图推进、德军试图撤退的同一条干线上。这就是与北非的不同之处，
where the Allies had developed this very mechanised, kit-heavy approach to war that basically involved blowing things up, right? And there, there aren't major centres of mechanized, kit-heavy approach to war that basically involved kind of blowing things up, right? And there, there aren't major centers of habitation, but now they're doing it in very, very inhabited reaches of the road and so on. And so they are kind of destroying people's homes in the name of giving them liberty. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. And how much bad do you have to do to achieve good? I mean, the moral conundrum of the Great Crusade, in inverted commas, is, yeah, I think I just find it so endlessly fascinating. It's so interesting. It's impossible to kind of read diaries of Italians and letters of Italians and not feel deeply for their plight and for the awful dilemmas in which they find themselves. So you quote a New Zealander who is watching a tank destroy a house. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And the Italian family are watching it.
在那里，盟军发展出了一种非常机械化、重装备的战争方式，基本上就是把东西炸毁，对吧？那里没有大型的人口中心，但现在他们在人口非常稠密的道路上这样做。所以他们是在以给予自由的名义摧毁人们的家园。是的，完全正确。完全正确。为了实现善，你必须做多少恶？我的意思是，所谓的“伟大十字军东征”的道德困境，是的，我觉得这真是令人着迷。太有趣了。读着意大利人的日记和信件，不可能不对他们的困境以及他们所处的可怕两难境地感到深深的同情。所以你引用了一位看着坦克摧毁房屋的新西兰人的话。是的，是的，是的。而那户意大利人家正看着这一幕。
And obviously they're distraught because everything they own has gone. And this New Zealander reflects on the challenge of fighting fascists who are embedded among civilians. And he says, you are in the way or out of the way, a yard or an inch can spell the difference between life and death, destruction or deliverance. embedded among civilians. And he says, you are in the way or out of the way, a yard or an inch can
显然他们心碎了，因为他们拥有的一切都没了。这位新西兰人反思了在平民中作战的法西斯分子的挑战。他说，你在路上还是不在路上，一码或一英寸的距离可能就是生与死、毁灭与拯救的区别。在平民中作战。他说，你在路上还是不在路上，一码或一英寸的距离可能
spell the difference between life and death, destruction or deliverance. And that, of course, this year, of all years, I mean, it has a kind of resonance, doesn't it? Yeah. I mean, it's just incredible. And I was lucky enough to read a lot of diaries from Benedictine monks through to civilians in Eberle, through to civilians in Naples, to Waltona on the Adriatic coast and all over. What one has to also remember about Italy is that it's basically completely Catholic, but they have more regional patois in Italy than any other country in Europe. That tells you about the isolated nation of it. When one's thinking about the puffed out chests and cockerel feathers in helmets and black shirts of fascism in the Mussolini era, don't be confused with thinking
就是生与死、毁灭与拯救的区别。当然，今年，在所有年份中，这有一种共鸣，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，这简直不可思议。我很幸运读到了很多日记，从本笃会僧侣到埃博利的平民，再到那不勒斯的平民，一直到亚得里亚海沿岸的瓦尔托纳等等。关于意大利，人们还必须记住的是，它基本上完全是天主教国家，但意大利的地区方言比欧洲任何其他国家都多。这说明了它的孤立性。当人们想到墨索里尼时代法西斯主义者挺起的胸膛、头盔上的公鸡羽毛和黑衫时，不要混淆地认为
that's Italy all over. This is Turin and Milan and Florence and Rome or whatever. But large parts of Italy are incredibly parochial and out of the way. And you're dealing with villages and towns, which, I mean, they're sort of peasant farmers that have been farming the same way for centuries. You know, the rhythms of life and the annual agricultural farming year have kind of remained untouched in centuries. You know, these are completely out of touch places and they're not particularly fascist. You know, it's why all these towns are on top of hills. They're very sort of isolated. And suddenly you've got this incredibly modern, highly mechanized war just sort of descending on them, like this sort of huge storm of destruction,
那就是整个意大利。那是都灵、米兰、佛罗伦萨和罗马等等。但意大利的大部分地区是非常狭隘和偏远的。你面对的是村庄和城镇，我的意思是，他们是那种几百年来一直以同样方式耕作的农民。你知道，生活的节奏和每年的农业耕作年份几个世纪以来都没有改变。你知道，这些地方完全与世隔绝，他们并不是特别法西斯。你知道，这就是为什么所有这些城镇都在山顶上。它们非常孤立。突然间，这种极其现代、高度机械化的战争降临到他们身上，就像一场巨大的毁灭风暴，
which is why I call it the savage storm. Savage storm, yeah. Well, exactly that. But it really, really was. And whether it's Batapelia or Altavelia or Naples, or whether it's the tiny little mountain village of San Pietro in Fine, a little bit further north, these lives are just completely and utterly destroyed. And it's really clear. I mean, when one drives around Italy now, you can always tell the town where the wars pass through, because they're absolutely gapping. I mean, they're full of horrid 1960s buildings. You can always tell, and it's just a scale of destruction, particularly on this path along the Adriatic and this path going up from sort of Salerno to Naples,
这就是我称之为“野蛮风暴”的原因。野蛮风暴，是的。嗯，正是如此。但它确实、确实是这样。无论是巴塔帕利亚、阿塔维拉还是那不勒斯，或者是再往北一点的圣彼得罗因菲内那个小山村，这些生命都被彻底摧毁了。这非常清楚。我的意思是，当你现在开车在意大利四处走动时，你总是能看出战争经过的城镇，因为它们完全是残缺不全的。我的意思是，它们充满了可怕的20世纪60年代的建筑。你总是能看出来，这只是破坏的规模，特别是在亚得里亚海沿岸的这条路径上，以及从萨莱诺到那不勒斯的那条路径上，
following the old Roman Via Casalina, you know, Highway 6 as it was, which goes from Naples to Rome. All along that road, it's just a litany of destruction. I mean, you and I, Brad, were talking about Capua on the weekend. You know, the road just passes straight through Cap straight through Capua, Caserta and so on. This place is absolutely hammered. It's so depressing. Let's talk a tiny bit about the Germans, James. Yes. So you were saying that Kesselring, his newfound prominence means he's now got Hitler's eye on him and it makes it more difficult for him to maneuver. What do he and the other German high command, what do they think they're going to get out of this campaign? So, for example, they don't give up Rome.
沿着古罗马的卡西利纳大道，也就是当时的6号公路，从那不勒斯通往罗马。在那条路沿线，简直是一连串的破坏。我的意思是，布拉德，你和我周末在谈论卡普阿。你知道，公路直接穿过卡普阿、卡塞塔等等。这个地方被彻底摧毁了。太令人沮丧了。让我们稍微谈谈德国人，詹姆斯。是的。所以你说凯塞林新获得的地位意味着他现在受到了希特勒的关注，这使他更难机动。他和德国最高统帅部认为他们能从这场战役中得到什么？例如，他们没有放弃罗马。
People thought they might withdraw north of Rome. You might have made an argument for them withdrawing right up to the north of Italy, withdrawing to the foothills of the Alps or something. Yeah, very good argument, I'd say. Why don't they do that? Do they think that they can basically tie down the Allies and bleed them dry as they move up the peninsula? No, it all goes back to that early stage. It's the early plan when Salerno happens, Operation Avalanche happens, that Castlering is planning to kick them back into sea,
人们以为他们可能会撤退到罗马以北。你可能会提出一个论点，让他们撤退到意大利最北部，撤退到阿尔卑斯山脚下什么的。是的，很好的论点，我会说。为什么他们不这样做？他们是否认为他们基本上可以拖住盟军，并在他们向半岛推进时耗尽他们的力量？不，这一切都回到了早期阶段。这是早期计划，当萨莱诺发生时，“雪崩”行动发生时，凯塞林正计划把他们踢回海里，
then clear out the zone. He thinks he can hold the whole of Italy. Well, if you can hold the whole of Italy, then there is a reason for fighting south of Rome. If you can't hold the whole of Italy, then there is no reason for fighting south of Rome. If you can't hold the whole of Italy, then there is no reason for fighting south of Rome at all, because you've lost Foggia, which is so important. That is the crucial bit. That's where the Allies' strategic airpower can come in and make a firm base. You've lost all those ports, Brindisi, Bari, Taranto, Naples, Salerno itself. You've lost all those ports. There's no point. What you really want is to be shortening your lines of supply. The the Pisa Rimini line, which is where Hitler is originally going to retreat to, should the Allies invade, that's his original plan earlier in the year, should it happen. And it is certainly the one
然后清理该区域。他认为他可以守住整个意大利。好吧，如果你能守住整个意大利，那么在罗马以南作战就有理由。如果你不能守住整个意大利，那么在罗马以南作战就毫无理由。如果你不能守住整个意大利，那么在罗马以南作战就完全没有理由，因为你已经失去了福贾，那太重要了。那是关键点。那是盟军战略空中力量可以进入并建立稳固基地的地方。你失去了所有那些港口，布林迪西、巴里、塔兰托、那不勒斯、萨莱诺本身。你失去了所有那些港口。没意义了。你真正想要的是缩短你的补给线。比萨-里米尼防线，那是希特勒最初打算撤退到的地方，如果盟军入侵的话，那是他今年早些时候的最初计划，如果它发生的话。而且这当然是
that Erwin Rommel, the Desert Fox, who is in charge of German forces in the north of Italy when the Allies invade at the start of September, that is his recommendation, having been on the receiving end of the Allies. But Kesselring is a sort of relentless optimist. I mean, he's not sort of half full. He's brimming over all the time. And actually, that's not a particularly good asset to have if you're a kind of a senior high commander. You want to have a sort of healthy dose of realism. And when his big plan fails at Salerno, the whole strategy for reclaiming the whole of Italy falls down like skittles. And then he gets stuck because he's got the Hitlerians in the spotlight. There is no sense,
埃尔温·隆美尔，那位“沙漠之狐”，在9月初盟军入侵时负责意大利北部的德军，这是他的建议，因为他曾是盟军攻击的对象。但凯塞林是一个彻头彻尾的乐观主义者。我的意思是，他不是那种半杯水的人。他总是充满信心。实际上，如果你是一名高级指挥官，这并不是一个特别好的资产。你想要有一种健康的现实主义。当他的大计划在萨莱诺失败时，收复整个意大利的整个战略就像九柱戏一样倒塌了。然后他被困住了，因为他受到了希特勒的聚光灯关注。没有任何意义，
no strategic sense whatsoever for fighting south of Rome once you've lost Foggia. And the German commanders are absolutely loggerheads. Most of them absolutely loathe Kesselring because he's a Luftwaffe field marshal, not a ground commander. And he's taken on this role as an army group commander and has all the kind of prestige that that allows, but without the kind of training and knowledge to be able to pull it off. He's got, broadly speaking in history, he's seen as a reasonably good German and has got a reasonably good press, but I think he was absolutely crap. Okay. Punchy take there. So this is terrible for everybody. Everybody.
一旦你失去了福贾，在罗马以南作战就没有任何战略意义。德国指挥官们完全陷入了僵局。他们中的大多数人非常厌恶凯塞林，因为他是一名空军元帅，而不是地面指挥官。他承担了这个集团军群司令的角色，并拥有所有随之而来的声望，但却没有能够实现这一目标的训练和知识。他在历史上被广泛认为是一名相当不错的德国人，并获得了相当不错的评价，但我认为他简直烂透了。好吧。很有力的观点。所以这对每个人来说都是可怕的。每个人。
It's terrible for the Germans. Awful for the Germans. Who end up having to use heated child's urine as antiseptic, which I think is always a sign that the war isn't going well if you're in that state of play. No. It's terrible for the Italians who are caught in the middle of these two meat grinders going at each other. Yes. You have an awful description of two women who are machine gunned while going to fetch water from a stream that runs at the bottom of the village. Rosa Fuoco. Nobody can go and get the water and so the whole village kind of dies of thirst.
这对德国人来说很可怕。对德国人来说太糟糕了。他们最终不得不使用加热的儿童尿液作为防腐剂，我认为如果你处于那种状态，这总是战争进展不顺利的迹象。不。这对夹在两个绞肉机中间的意大利人来说很可怕。是的。你对两名妇女在去小溪取水时被机枪扫射的描述很可怕，那条小溪在村子底部。罗莎·福科。没有人能去取水，所以整个村子因口渴而死。
This is San Pietro, yeah. I mean, that's kind of awful. And it's awful for the allies who are having to slog at the passage that Dominic read at the head of this second half. And again, you've written so much about the Second World War, and yet you seem kind of overwhelmed by the horror of this second half. And again, you've written so much about the Second World War, and yet you seem kind of overwhelmed by the horror of the fighting here. So you write about the conditions. I continue to be in awe of how the Allies kept going. Why should a Texan boy be fighting up a mountain in a desolate corner of Italy, or a New Zealander be wading across the icy Sangro? It is astonishing that they did so. Yeah, I think the scale of destruction and the scale of the violence was shocking. And I think largely because when one thinks of the Italian
这是圣彼得罗，是的。我的意思是，那太可怕了。这对盟军来说也很可怕，他们不得不像多米尼克在这一半开头读到的那样艰难跋涉。而且，你写了这么多关于第二次世界大战的书，但你似乎被这一半的恐怖所淹没。而且，你写了这么多关于第二次世界大战的书，但你似乎被这里的战斗恐怖所淹没。所以你写了关于条件的内容。我仍然对盟军如何坚持下去感到敬畏。为什么一个德克萨斯男孩要在一个荒凉的意大利角落爬山作战，或者一个新西兰人要涉水穿过冰冷的桑格罗河？他们这样做真是令人震惊。是的，我认为破坏的规模和暴力的规模令人震惊。而且我认为很大程度上是因为当人们想到意大利
campaign, most people think of sort of Anzio and Cassino, and I suppose ultimately the fall of Rome, and then don't give it much further thought. So there's not much after Cassino, and there's not much before Cassino either. And I would say these very crucial months and the back end of 1943, where Allied strategy is sort of taking a little bit of a hiccup because of the kind of huge global weight that they put upon their shoulders, and for the preparation for Overlord and all the rest of it, means that Italy falls short. There's very good reasons for going in still. There's very good reasons for staying there, but they're not able to do it at kind normal levels of support, material support and shipping support, crucially, that they would normally expect.
战役时，大多数人想到的是安齐奥和卡西诺，我想最终是罗马的陷落，然后就不会再多想了。所以卡西诺之后没多少内容，卡西诺之前也没多少内容。我想说的是，1943年年底这些非常关键的几个月，盟军战略因为他们肩负的巨大全球压力，以及为“霸王行动”所做的准备等等，出现了一点小插曲，意味着意大利战役没能达到预期。进入意大利仍然有很好的理由。留在那里也有很好的理由，但他们无法在他们通常期望的正常水平的支持、物质支持和航运支持下做到这一点。
And I'll give you an example of this. Once they do get into Normandy, Allied infantry battalions, which is your sort of basic unit of 845 men or something, you wouldn't expect them to fight in the front line for more than four to six days max. But in Italy, they're fighting for kind of two weeks solidly. The physical and mental strain of that is just enormous, particularly when you've got sort of endless rain and all the privations you get of kind of operating in extreme mud in the valley floors and in extremely bare and naked positions on the top of mountains. So I was shocked. But I think the other main reason is that for the first time, I've really focused all my personal accounts on contemporary sources, diaries, letters, and so on, rather than
我给你举个例子。一旦他们进入诺曼底，盟军步兵营，也就是你那种845人左右的基本单位，你不会期望他们在前线战斗超过四到六天。但在意大利，他们连续战斗了大约两周。这种身体和精神上的压力是巨大的，特别是当你面对无休止的雨水，以及在山谷底部极度泥泞和山顶极度裸露的位置作战所带来的所有匮乏时。所以我感到震惊。但我认为另一个主要原因是，这是我第一次真正将我所有的个人叙述集中在当代资料、日记、信件等上，而不是
post-war oral testimonies, which actually I'm sort of now questioning a little bit because what does someone remember 60 years after the day? I mean, they can remember sort of key things, but you can't remember that specific detail of what you were feeling on that particular day. Whereas a diary and a letter tells you what was going on on that particular moment. And I suppose the vividness of those recollections really brings into sharp focus the scales of destruction and violence in a way that I probably underestimated before. Well, since you're talking about the challenge of writing history and about the recollections that people have, we've actually got a question from one of our listeners, from Theo Young-Smith. And he says, could you please ask James Holland to talk about the role of women in the Italian campaign? So what do you have to say about that, James?
战后的口述证词，我现在对此有点怀疑，因为一个人在事后60年能记住什么？我的意思是，他们能记住一些关键的事情，但你无法记住你在那一天具体感受到的那种细节。而日记和信件告诉你那一刻发生了什么。我想这些回忆的生动性确实以一种我以前可能低估的方式突显了破坏和暴力的规模。好吧，既然你在谈论撰写历史的挑战以及人们的回忆，我们实际上收到了我们的一位听众西奥·杨-史密斯的问题。他说，你能请詹姆斯·霍兰德谈谈女性在意大利战役中的作用吗？那么，詹姆斯，你对此有什么看法？
Well, does he mean in uniform or does he mean civilians? Because obviously there were a lot of Italian women caught up in this. A huge number of young men were away in prison of war camps by this stage in Canada and Britain and the United States and elsewhere. A lot of women were having to fend for themselves. And it's estimated by the US Fifth Army General Medical Officer that 50%, at least 50% of all available women, his words, had some kind of form of sexually transmitted disease by the spring of 1944. Oh my word. And that's because of prostitution? Yes, because that's the only way they can survive. It's by prostituting themselves to allied troops in return for cans of fruit and syrup and all the rest of it. I mean,
嗯，他是指穿制服的还是指平民？因为显然有很多意大利妇女卷入了这场战争。在这个阶段，大量的年轻男子被关在加拿大、英国、美国和其他地方的战俘营里。许多妇女不得不自谋生路。据美国第五集团军总医官估计，到1944年春天，所有可用的妇女（他的原话）中至少有50%患有某种形式的性传播疾病。天哪。这是因为卖淫吗？是的，因为那是她们生存的唯一途径。她们通过向盟军士兵卖淫来换取罐装水果、糖浆等等。我的意思是，
it's just absolutely horrendous. But in terms of military personnel, yes, there were a huge number of nurses. They were incredibly courageous. And actually, a lot of these field hospitals, they weren't absolutely in the direct front line, but they were very much in the firing line. And there were lots of them. So we're now in December and 80 years ago, the Allies had not broken through to Rome. They had not got there. It wasn't going to be over by Christmas. They are, as you said, very anxious of a potential Western front situation. And so essentially they are increasingly relying on their superior firepower to try and blast their way through. And you mentioned the most significant architectural victim of this approach,
这简直太可怕了。但就军事人员而言，是的，有大量的护士。她们非常勇敢。实际上，许多野战医院，它们并不完全在前线，但它们确实处于交火线中。而且她们有很多。所以我们现在在12月，80年前，盟军还没有突破到罗马。他们还没有到达那里。战争不会在圣诞节前结束。他们正如你所说，非常担心潜在的西线情况。所以本质上，他们越来越依赖他们优越的火力来试图炸开一条路。你提到了这种方法最显著的建筑受害者，
which is fought in 1944, so the next year, and that is the Abbey of Monte Cassino, founded by Saint Benedict and rebuilt over many centuries, one of the holiest places in Italian Catholicism. And I mean, just to end this episode with the drumbeat to that catastrophe, which is starting to be sounded in the dying days of 1943. So 17th of October, the treasures of the abbey start to be removed by the Germans. Many of their commanders are Catholic, so they're not just doing it in a cynical spirit. They are genuinely worried about what is coming. The German high command then proclaim a neutral zone around the abbey, which is what, kind of 300 meters all around? Yes, and is completely disabused.
也就是1944年，也就是下一年，那就是蒙特卡西诺修道院，由圣本笃创立，历经数百年重建，是意大利天主教最神圣的地方之一。我的意思是，就在这一集的结尾，那场灾难的鼓声在1943年的最后几天开始响起。所以10月17日，修道院的宝藏开始被德国人移走。他们的许多指挥官是天主教徒，所以他们不仅仅是以愤世嫉俗的精神这样做。他们确实担心即将发生的事情。德国最高统帅部随后宣布修道院周围为中立区，那是多少，大约周围300米？是的，而且完全被滥用了。
And then on Christmas day, you were talking about the value of reading diaries, that you have a diary of a monk in Monte Cassino. Yes, Don Musebio. And he confides to his diary, his confidence that the protection zone will be respected. And of course, it won't be. Oh, it's so awful. It's so awful. That reading this book, it ends, you know, as the year turns from 43 to 44. And you have a sense the worst is yet to come.
然后在圣诞节那天，你在谈论阅读日记的价值，你有一本蒙特卡西诺僧侣的日记。是的，多恩·穆塞比奥。他在日记中吐露了他对保护区将得到尊重的信心。当然，它不会。哦，这太可怕了。这太可怕了。读这本书，它结束了，你知道，随着年份从43年转到44年。你有一种感觉，最坏的情况还在后面。
I know. All these horrors you've described. And yet, Monte Cassino hasn't even been fired at yet. No, I know. It is amazing. And Dom Eusebio, who's the diary you're talking about, the Benedictine monk, it's so moving because what you realise is that this tiny little community in the monastery, they're so ill-equipped to deal with the catastrophe which is befalling them. The father abbot, he just doesn't know what to do. They are incredibly learned, incredibly ascetic, incredibly religious,
我知道。你描述的所有这些恐怖。然而，蒙特卡西诺甚至还没有被开火。不，我知道。这太令人惊奇了。多恩·尤塞比奥，也就是你谈到的那个日记作者，那位本笃会僧侣，这太感人了，因为你意识到修道院里的这个小社区，他们对降临在他们身上的灾难是多么准备不足。院长，他只是不知道该怎么办。他们非常博学，非常苦行，非常虔诚，
obviously, but they're just not equipped to deal with a war passing through them. They just don't know what to do. They don't know what to do for the best. And the father abbot is repeatedly in tears trying to make the right decision. Do we hand over the treasures to the Germans? Will they flog it, take it back to Germany? Will it be safe? What do we do? How do we secure a 300-metre zone? And it's just desperate. And Domus Sebbia, who is only, I think, 32 at the time, he's writing this diary, is a very perceptive diary keeper. And I will just give you one spoiler alert for what follows, is that he suddenly gets a bad cold in January, and it then gets worse, and it gets worse, and it gets worse. And then on the 13th of February, he dies. It's absolutely heartbreaking.
显然，但他们只是没有准备好应对一场经过他们的战争。他们只是不知道该怎么办。他们不知道什么是最好的。院长多次流泪，试图做出正确的决定。我们把宝藏交给德国人吗？他们会卖掉它，把它带回德国吗？它会安全吗？我们该怎么办？我们如何确保300米的区域？这简直是绝望。多恩·塞比亚，当时我想只有32岁，他在写这本日记，是一个非常有洞察力的日记记录者。我只会给你一个关于接下来发生的事情的剧透，那就是他在1月份突然得了重感冒，然后它变得更糟，更糟，更糟。然后在2月13日，他去世了。这简直令人心碎。
And his body is still in the crypt when two days later, the monastery is destroyed. It's just, it's so profoundly moving. I can't tell you. It really is. And that's the other advantage, I think, in a sort of cynical kind of writery way of using diaries is that obviously if you're relying on oral testimony, self-evidently they've survived. Whereas with diaries, you don't know whether the diary keeper is going to make it through.
当两天后修道院被摧毁时，他的尸体还在地窖里。这简直太感人了。我无法告诉你。确实如此。我认为以一种愤世嫉俗的写作方式使用日记的另一个好处是，显然如果你依赖口述证词，不言而喻他们幸存了下来。而对于日记，你不知道日记记录者是否能挺过来。
The jeopardy is that much greater yeah well bro on that cheery note yes thank you so much oh well thank you for having me on happy christmas everyone and what could be more festive than the savage storm the battle for italy 1943 by james holland who is also of course presenter of the brilliant second world war podcast we have Have Ways of Making You Talk. And on that bombshell, literally, James, thank you so much. Tom, was that a tour de force? Does that count as a tour de force by your definition? I would say it was an explosive tour de force.
这种危险要大得多，是的。好吧，布拉德，在那个愉快的音符上，是的，非常感谢你。哦，好吧，谢谢你邀请我。祝大家圣诞快乐，还有什么比詹姆斯·霍兰德的《野蛮风暴：1943年意大利之战》更具节日气氛的呢？他当然也是精彩的二战播客《我们有让你开口的方法》的主持人。在那颗重磅炸弹上，字面意思上，詹姆斯，非常感谢你。汤姆，那是一场杰作吗？按照你的定义，那算是一场杰作吗？我会说那是一场爆炸性的杰作。
Savage storm. Wonderful. All right. Thank you very much, James. Savage storm, everybody. And of course, We Have Ways of Making You Talk is our sister podcast. In fact, it's our progenitor, really, isn really isn't it tom because it was the first goal hanger podcast it is yes yes yes i remember saying to tony you know what you should talk to my bro
野蛮风暴。太棒了。好的。非常感谢你，詹姆斯。野蛮风暴，大家。当然，《我们有让你开口的方法》是我们的姐妹播客。事实上，它是我们的始祖，真的，不是吗，汤姆？因为它是第一个Goalhanger播客。是的，是的，是的，我记得我对托尼说，你知道你应该和我兄弟谈谈。
oh my word there you go with those words a terrible monster was born a typhoon of steel one might say well it's a great honour to be on. Thank you very much for having me on. Absolute pleasure. All right. Bye-bye, everybody. Bye-bye, everyone. Cheerio.
哦，我的天哪，你用那些话，一个可怕的怪物诞生了，可以说是一场钢铁台风。好吧，能参加真是我的荣幸。非常感谢你邀请我。绝对是我的荣幸。好的。再见，大家。再见，每个人。再见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。